Lord of the Rings meets end of watch
with nowhere near the chemistry I'm
interested bright so bright directed by
David Ayer he directed fury here also
directed that other movie I still hear
about to this day stars Will Smith and
Joel Edgerton Will Smith is a cop in LA
Joel Edgerton is an orc who's also a cop
in LA and the weird thing about this
world is it's taken a lot of fantasy
elements and integrated them into our
society it's like a dimension ripped
open they were like hey we're here now
so let's integrate now they talk about
events that happened a couple thousand
years ago so though they don't go into
great detail it's safe to assume this is
just an alternate reality to our own
it's a world that's our world but it's
just it has fancy elements in it
centaurs fairies orcs elves in modern
day which is used in the movie to show
racial profiling doesn't really land the
way they want it to in there it's just
so on the nose fairy lives don't matter
today is a line in the movie butterfly
effect says if that's the case if all of
this stuff are events that happened a
couple thousand years ago and just the
magical world has evolved into a modern
world world to be really different they
make an Alamo reference and a Shrek
reference butterfly effect says the
Alamo probably wouldn't have happened
and Shrek if it did happen would
probably be I don't know some history
piece if at all is it shrek exists
because orcs don't exist that's what
makes shrek fun so if orcs did exist I
don't think Shrek would happen that's
just me nitpicking knows where my brain
goes it kind of takes me out of it but
the point of the movie is to have a
modern world that looks like our world
so you can't alter it too much otherwise
it ceases to be our world and the
interesting parts gone but I like about
this movie is the concept the concept of
bright is way more interesting than the
execution of bright either the movie
can't be enjoyable you have a couple of
cops one of them is an orc the orcs kind
of a loners are looking for this wand
because wands are super Opie ultimately
an escort mission for 75% of the movie
yeah I think these young elf girl with a
wand and escort it from A to B that's
what they got to do all the while there
are other elves and magical beings on
their trail you'd cause him trouble
along the way and get into a couple of
gang fights one with a human gang
another with an orc gang the script is
that dude there are lines in this movie
I'm like that was written and that went
past a lot of people I don't know if it
was ad libbed
or if that was actually in the script we
are the cavalry I am the city mm-hmm and
Will Smith and Joel Edgerton for a long
period of time in this movie didn't
really have
so their chemistry was pretty [ __ ] by
the end it pays off because there's
supposed to be a couple of cops who
don't want to be cops together but most
of the good cop movies I know even if
they don't want to be cops they find a
way to make it work and earlier on they
started to see the quality of this
partnership this movie I was like come
on you guys would be better off alone
it's not even the fun bickering there is
this scene at the beginning where
they're in a car together and they're
just arguing for so long that was like
scenes still going what's happening and
as much as I do not have the cleanest
mouth I've ever met they say the word
[ __ ] way too much Tarantino ends up
doing it in a stylistic way that
actually makes it amusing and funny
generally speaking Quentin Tarantino
illustrates the true diversity of the
effort this movie was like all right
they have to say [ __ ] every other
sentence otherwise it's just not gonna
be hard gore it just took me out of it
it's like everyone was just posturing be
like hey I cursed that means I'm tough
that means weren't awesome rated R movie
on Netflix I shouldn't see it that way
at a point in this movie I was like this
officially feels like a straight-to-dvd
movie or made-for-tv movie or straight
to blu-ray movie however you want to
phrase it these days point is a movie
that didn't come out in theaters I don't
even know this movie is in theaters and
the movie is way too long this movie
we're generously 15 minutes or so
shorter it would have focused up the
point you would have yourself a pretty
solid Netflix movie the fact that drags
on does drag it down because in the end
bright was a mixed bag for me the lore
is interesting the world itself the
concept is interesting I'm sure it
wanted to be as cool and stylistic as
fables or the wolf among us at a live
action movie version but the movie
itself was bland at times the script was
[ __ ] at times some of the editing
choices were a little obscure - it's
almost like initially in filming they
went from point A to point C and they
were like aw crap we had to show what
happened in B so we have to go back and
read film but just feels choppy but
there's fun you can have in here if
you're a fantasy fan like myself and you
want to see a merging of a fantasy world
and a cop movie in our modern day in the
end I will say the world of bright has
potential I saw that potential in some
scenes and by the end Joel Edgerton and
Will Smith didn't annoy me together like
they did near the beginning and bright
can have some enjoyment if you're drunk
ya know it's a buddy I'm not gonna lie
shot down over okay let's Massacre a
movie but the Internet's talking about
how this might be the worst bus fire
they've seen all year and I was like
it's not that terrible I mean it's not
great but it has some enjoyment in there
all right guys so bright on Netflix have
you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]